hey schön dass ihr dabei sein zdf heute
live wahrscheinlich merkt er dass alle
im moment sei es an der tankstelle im
supermarkt oder beim ausgehen die preise
steigen durchschnittlich sind es 7,6
prozent mehr im moment und das trifft
uns alle klar aber natürlich trifft es
die die weniger geld haben um so härter
ab morgen steigt zwar der mindestlohn
ein wenig an doch die grundsicherung
also die unterstützung für
arbeitssuchende menschen die bleibt
weiter niedrig viel zu niedrig das sagen
die einen da ist kein menschenwürdiges
leben möglich gut so wo bleibt sonst der
anreiz sich einen job zu suchen selbst
geld zu verdienen das sagen die anderen
aber ist das wirklich so haben wirklich
alle die gleichen chancen armut
betroffen selbst schuld das ist heute
unser thema und wir diskutieren darüber
mit sarah die heinrich sie ist die
bundessprecherin der grünen jugend sie
ist als tochter einer alleinerziehenden
mutter mit hartz4 aufgewachsen und sie
selbst sagt hartz4 ist der größte scheiß
und wir diskutieren mit sozial
unternehmerin emi tispol sie ist mit 13
uhr ohne ihre eltern aus dem iran nach
deutschland geflüchtet hat sich
hochgearbeitet eine eigene werbeagentur
und einen verein für frauen aus
benachteiligten verhältnissen gegründet
und ich freue mich sehr dass die beiden
gleich meine gäste sind aber zuerst
wollen wir uns anschauen was es
eigentlich bedeutet aktuell von
grundsicherung oder von hartz iv zu
leben ein beitrag von christian hoch und
franziska von tiesenhausen
hashtag ich bin armut betroffen und
heute gab es geld abzüglich von circa 60
euro die ich zur miete zu zahlen muss
das kann ich aber nicht verballern wie
einige behaupten sondern rechne jetzt
schon für den ganzen monat damit es zum
existieren reicht tag zwei im monat
miete weg strom weg raten weg erster
einkauf weg rechnungen weg und schwupps
ist nur noch ein bruchteil des geldes
dar mit dem gilt es dann irgendwie den
ganzen monat zu überstehen hashtag ich
bin armut betroffen auch für jörg
mertens ist der alltag aktuell eine
herkulesaufgabe wegen der hohen preise
kann er sich zurzeit nur die hälfte der
lebensmittel leisten die er sonst
gekauft hätte
der gelernte sachbearbeiter musste wegen
verschiedener erkrankungen aufhören zu
arbeiten lebt jetzt von einer
erwerbsminderungsrente und
grundsicherung nach abzug aller kosten
bleiben ihm 460 euro zum leben ich muss
mir jetzt wirklich gedanken machen ob
ich tage einlegen wo ich ganz bewusst
einfach hungere damit ich den anderen
tag eine volle mahlzeit essen kam mit
seiner geschichte ist jörg mertens in
deutschland nicht allein rund 13,8
millionen menschen gelten hier als armut
betroffen auch an iw kann aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht arbeiten
lebt von hartz iv mitte mai teilt sie
auf twitter den hashtag ich bin armut
betroffen ihre geschichte geht viral ich
erhoffe mir dadurch einfach noch mehr
sichtbarkeit
das ist für mich die intention die ich
hab da und das ist für mich wichtig dass
so viele menschen wie möglich zeigen wir
wollen mit dem klischee auf aus den
tweets ist eine kleine bewegung
entstanden mit bundesweiten
demonstration die botschaft vor allem
armut betroffene menschen dürfen mit den
steigenden preisen und der hohen
inflation nicht alleine gelassen werden
sara lee du bist selbst mit deiner
mutter unter hartz 4 umständen groß
geworden und sagst eben selbst hartz 4
ist der größte scheiß warum
ja erstmal auch halo von meiner seite
ich freue mich riesig dass wir heute die
möglichkeit haben auch den blick auf die
ärmsten in der gesellschaft zu richten
was die menschen unter hashtag ich bin
armut betroffen jetzt schon seit wochen
im internet und auch auf der straße
machen als ich mich damals quasi geoutet
habe als eine person die in hartz4
aufgewachsen ist und in hartz4 lebt
hätte ich mir auch gewünscht so viele
andere menschen zu sehen die ihr
schicksal teilen als ich das damals
geschrieben habe ich bin bei meiner
alleinerziehende mutter aufgewachsen da
ging es uns sowieso gerade nicht gut man
hat ständige existenzängste aber der
grund warum es mich so hart getroffen
hat und warum ich meine wut damals uns
auf twitter quasi ausgelassen hat war
weil ich selbst eigentlich gerade dabei
war mein abitur zu machen und
auszuziehen und mir aufgefallen ist wie
viele steine
gerade kindern in hartz iv in den weg
gelegt werden
man kann kaum etwas dazu verdienen das
wird sich jetzt durch die ampel bald
ändern man hat kaum rücklagen und auch
keine eltern die einen so einfach
unterstützen können wenn es dann darum
geht aus der armut herauszukommen und
wir haben in deutschland total das
problem dass armut kinderarbeit quasi
dann zu erwachsenen armut wird und dann
wieder zu neuer kinderarmut und ich
würde sagen hat vier trägt er dazu bei
weil hat viele menschen mehr in der
armut hält als dass es menschen aus der
armut rausholt und da gibt es viele
punkte aber ich werde jetzt nicht mit
einem rap ganzen referat anfangen
weswegen ich sagen würde hat vier gehört
reformiert abgeschafft und durch eine
richtige grundsicherung ersetzt die
menschen ein leben in würde ermöglicht
und im ead ist du arbeitest tagtäglich
mit frauen aus benachteiligten
verhältnissen zusammen in dem verein den
du gegründet hast äußerst sich aber auch
kritisch in dem du sagst dass du davor
warnt dass manche die hartz4 bekommen
das system ausnutzen würden und dass sie
vielleicht auch faul würden wieso ist
das deine haltung zu diesem thema
ja es war wunderschön guten abend und
schön dass ich heute hier dabei sein
darf und mitdiskutieren darf ja ich
erlebe in den letzten
tagen besonders war ich habe seitdem ich
auch mein verein gegründet habe ist ja
jetzt seit erst märz praktisch
unterhalten wir uns oft mit sozial
benachteiligte frauen vor allem hartz iv
empfängerinnen und sie erzählen uns ihre
geschichten aber es gibt immer wieder
auch schwarze schafe also es gibt viele
auch die sagten warum soll ich arbeiten
gehen ich krieg doch ein hartz4
empfänger satz und wenn ich als kellner
oder als pflegerin arbeite
kriege ich sowieso nicht mehr und
deswegen finde ich eigentlich wichtig
dass man seitens der politik wir müssen
mehr bonuspunkte verschaffen wir müssen
mehr zuschuss diese menschen noch geben
oder wir müssen auch mehr
für betreuung der kinder auch da sein
ich habe ich betreue viele auch
alleinerziehende frauen die haben vier
kinder die sagen klar wir haben wir
sprechen von fachkräftemangel geld in
der pflege oder auch in gastronomie no
ich kann keine schichtarbeit mir leiste
mit vier kinder als alleinerziehende
mutter wie soll das gehen und das ist
auch zu recht also wir haben wirklich
auch solche und solche die wirklich auch
arbeitswillig sehen zum beispiel ich
habe jetzt gerade eine frau eingestellt
sie war 14 jahre lang arbeitslos hat 14
jahre lang sich beworben und sie hatte
überhaupt keine möglichkeiten job zu
bekommen sagte du bist die einzige die
mir eine chance gegeben hat und weil ich
vielleicht alleine zehn war und ich
finde es einfach schade weil menschen
die anfang zu arbeiten und auch mal sich
im spiegel anschauen können auch vorbild
für ihre kinder sind haben sie manchmal
auch so das gefühl ich will nie wieder
zum jobcenter ich bin einfach nie wieder
damit zu tun haben und deshalb finde ich
einfach wichtig dass wir auch diese
frauen und diese menschen eine chance zu
geben aber diese schwarze schafe bin ich
der meinung müssen wir auch mehr
sanktionieren
sara lee gehst du damit mit sanktionen
für schwarze schafe wie mieter ist das
nennt ich gehe erst mal bei ganz vielen
dingen mit die miete ist gerade
geschildert hat denn wenn man sich
anschaut wer gerade hartz 4 beziehen
dann ist der anteil von den menschen die
darunter tatsächlich arbeitslos sind
erstmal eigentlich gering es ist nämlich
nur ein drittel wir haben ganz viele
menschen die pflegen angehörige wir
haben viele alleinerziehende die
arbeiten teilzeit und verdienen so wenig
dass sie aus was wir nicht raus kommen
wir haben über 100.000 leute die sogar
vollzeit arbeiten und aus hat hier nicht
raus kommen wir haben viele kinder in
hartz 4 und das finde ich immer total
wichtig aufzumachen und auch unter den
menschen die eben gerade arbeitslos sind
sind super viele arbeitssuchend aber wir
haben in deutschland viel mehr menschen
die arbeitslos sind als die passenden
stellen dafür und auch gut bezahlte
stellen gerade eben weil wir einen
niedriglohnsektor haben das sind viele
punkte bei denen ich mitgehe und die
frage die ich mir dann stelle was ist
der richtige hebel und gerade in einer
situation wo wir zum beispiel einen so
großen niedriglohnsektor haben wo uns
eigentlich total viele jobs gute jobs
fehlen in die wir menschen weiter
vermitteln können ich glaube die letzten
zahlen die ich hatte war so eine freie
stelle für arbeitslose personen dann
bringt es mir ja nichts quasi die
menschen die arbeit suchen und keine
finden zu sanktionieren das ist zum teil
gerade in hartz4 so wenn man auch den
schlechten job nicht annehmen möchte
wenn man den ein euro job nicht annehmen
möchte was ich sehr gut verstehen kann
wenn man nicht in einen 450 euro job
gehen möchte der quasi bedeutet dass man
schon mal keine renten punkte sammelt
und an altersarmut landet dann wird man
gerade dafür sanktioniert und das finde
ich falsch ich würde sagen die politik
hat eine verantwortung auch dafür zu
sorgen dass wir den arbeitsmarkt haben
auf denen niemand in armut lebt und da
ist noch viel zu tun und gerade eine
mindest lohnerhöhung sorgt zum beispiel
dafür dass viele menschen aus vier
ausfallen und ich glaube das sind die
hebel aber denen wir ansetzen müssen ich
glaube nicht dass die sanktionen dafür
der richtige hebel sind aber ich glaube
im ziel sind wir uns da erst mal einig
die miete ist willst du da direkt darauf
antworten und einen punkt mit den
sanktionen verteidigen oder
ja also okay vielleicht ist sanktionen
immer so hart aber dafür bin ich nur
bekannt dass ich immer so klar und meine
meinung äußere kein blatt vor dem mund
nehme vielleicht sollte man auch mit
bonuspunkte mir arbeiten zum beispiel
eine person die langzeitarbeitslos war
und und anfängt zu arbeiten dass man den
mäher auch fördert auch vielleicht auch
mal im bereich bildung weiterbildung
auch mal zuschüsse gibt und wenn die zb
die möglichkeit haben zu arbeiten auf
dem arbeitsmarkt nach drei monaten
bonuspunkte ein beispiel wenn eine frau
jetzt anfängt nach also ich spreche von
meiner assistentin zum beispiel nach 14
jahren anfängt zu arbeiten was ich
großartig finde das ist eine eher 16e
sgb 2 gibt das heißt sie wird zu 100
prozent erstmal gefördert zwei jahre
lang finde ich großartig tolle
unterstützung aber wenn ihr junger sohn
mit 14 jahren zeitungen austrägt und
dann gehalt von ihrem mama abgezogen
wird das finde ich einfach unfair weil
wie fühlt sich denn der junge das heißt
er wird dann irgendwann anfangen schwarz
zu arbeiten oder wird sagen ich gehe gar
nicht zu arbeiten dann werde ich auch
irgendwann hartz 4 empfänger und deshalb
müssen wir auch so was auch darauf
achten und auch seitens der politik
sollten wir da auch besser darauf
reagieren und vielleicht auch mit mehr
bonuspunkte arbeiten mehr zuschüsse und
auch mehr auch mal schauen wie können
wenn diese menschen weil wir sprechen
von arbeitskräftemangel in deutschland
in gastronomie in hotelbetriebe
im pflegebereich das heißt wir haben
diese probleme und dann holen wir
fachkräfte aus dem ausland
wir müssen diese menschen auch
motivieren dazu aber nicht immer sie
bestraft wenn es sie sagen du kriegst
einen zuschuss aber da muss er
einerseits mehr steuern bezahlen oder da
gibt es mir abzüge und das finde ich
sehr widersprüchlich was er da in unsere
politik ja auch heutzutage ja auch gang
und gäbe ist unsere user dürfen sollen
sich ja auch sehr gern an dieser
diskussion beteiligen also an alle
nochmal natürlich der herzliche aufruf
schreibt gerne eure fragen und
kommentare entweder per mail oder direkt
in den stream und ich habe auch schon
direkt die erste und zwar von nick
knatterton unsere user haben auch immer
sehr kreative namen bei youtube und zwar
geht die frage an dich sarah er fragt
sich weil du doch in der
regierungspartei bist warum ändert diese
partei diesen umstand nicht einfach
als um gespräche in der grünen jugend
stehe ich natürlich der grünen partei da
ich selbst dazu nicht im bundestag das
denken glaube ich manchmal leute und ich
finde es auch wichtig quasi auch mal von
außen kritik äußern zu können und ich
kann gar nicht widersprechen ich bin
unzufrieden mit dem was die ampel macht
als grüne jugend haben wir uns gemeinsam
mit den sozialverbänden und
gewerkschaften schon für das erste und
das zweite entlastungspaket eingesetzt
und ich würde sagen die reichen nicht
und die haben eigentlich nur gezeigt
dass die ampel sich erst dann bewegt
wenn der druck groß genug wird ich weiß
noch wie christian lindner das erst
entlastet das zweite ausgeschlossen hat
schon gesagt hat das machen wir jetzt
einfach nicht und zwei tage später hat
er seine meinung geändert weil wir es
eben eingefordert haben weil wir eben
gesagt haben nein ist es nicht in
ordnung dass man so viele menschen
stehen lässt ich bin nicht zufrieden
damit was gerade über die sozialen
fragen wenn man sieht sich im
koalitionsvertrag anschaut wenn ich
nicht zufrieden mit dem was ausgemacht
wurde und da muss mehr kommen gerade
wenn wir uns in herbst und winter
anschauen ich weiß nicht wie es euch
gerade geht und den vielen leuten die da
zuschauen aber ich habe ganz schön angst
vor meiner nächsten heizkostenabrechnung
weil ich jetzt nicht so viel einfach auf
der kante liegen habe und
da muss bewegung rein und da fangen
jetzt die debatten an ja jetzt müssen
wir aber hier und dort sparen jetzt wird
die krankenversicherung teurer
wer kann sich denn gerade höhere
krankenversicherungsbeiträge leisten das
macht mir sehr viel sorge und da habe
ich auch kritik da fühle ich mich jetzt
gar nicht in der rolle das ganze zu
verteidigen es geht auch vielen im
stream so ich möchte ja noch ein
kommentar mit reinbringen dass sie das
natürlich gerade betrifft und dass ihnen
das auch sorgen macht dass die preise
weiter steigen kafkas mir egal schreibt
bei youtube und mal ehrlich zu sein mein
gehalt wird auch nicht an die inflation
angepasst also da höre ich so ein
bisschen raus dass das ja alle betrifft
das ist richtig wir hören aber mal in
einen ton rein denn es ist natürlich
auch trotzdem so dass die inflation auch
eine schere auf macht eine schere
zwischen arm und reich die noch mehr
befeuert und wer mit einem
armutsforscher darüber gesprochen und
hören uns mal zusammen diesen ton an die
kluft zwischen arm und reich wird durch
die inflation vertieft und zwar deswegen
weil auf der einen seite haben wir einen
rekordstand bei den armutsgefährdeten
nämlich 16,6 prozent oder 13 8 millionen
menschen also 600.000 menschen mehr als
vor der pandemie auf der anderen seite
konzentriert sich der reichtum noch
stärker bei wenigen es gibt aber auch
hunderttausend
vermögensmillionäre mehr und das
zerreißt am ende natürlich die
gesellschaft der soziale zusammenhalt
schwindet dann wenn die menschen das
gefühl haben die
sozioökonomische situation der armen und
der wohlhabenden beziehungsweise reichen
driftet immer mehr auseinander
also in dieser situation glaube ich hat
die gesellschaft alle hände voll zu tun
um noch zusammen zu bleiben um auch
natürlich politisch zum beispiel denn es
geht natürlich auch um den erhalt der
demokratie
im etat ist wie siehst du das teilst du
das hast du sorge vor einer spaltung der
gesellschaft oder siehst du es nicht so
finster
doch ich sehe es zu 100 prozent als ich
nach deutschland kam vor 34 jahren war
die inflationsrate bei 1,2 prozent
und wenn man sich überlegt wir haben
natürlich nicht die er wir haben diese
wirtschaftliche probleme nicht wie heute
wären diese massen probleme nicht gabi
kohona wie krieg wie flüchtlingswelle
wir hatten den 90er jahren auch
flüchtlingswelle gab aber kann man bis
heute nicht vergleichen januar hatten
wir eine inflationsrate von 2,5 glaube
ich und heute sprechen von 7,6 prozent
und natürlich geht diese schere arm und
reich auseinander ich habe immer als ich
nach deutschland kam habe ich immer
gedacht deutschland steht für
mittelstand aber ich sehe diesen
mittelstand nicht mehr früher konnten
familien mit 22 kinder und vierköpfige
familie wo die frau hausfrau und der
mann gearbeitet kann sich ein haus
leisten wer kann sich denn heutzutage
als doppelverdiener sogar nach haus
leisten und ich mache mir schon gedanken
weil das spürt man mir auch dass die
heizkosten energiekosten lebensmittel
die steigen und ich kann mich nicht
daran erinnern dass jemals die kosten
gesunken sind und die energiepreise
werden leider so auch weiter bleiben und
auch ihr höher gehen ich kann mich auch
daran erinnern als die euro umstellung
war 2001 30 pfennig warum brötchen dann
war es ein 21 30 cent das heißt die
preise sind nie gesungen und wird ja
auch nicht so in die zukunft während
deshalb müssen wir dringend dieses thema
ernst nehmen auch seitens der politik
reagieren aber effizient und langfristig
aber nicht so kurzfristig wegen nur ein
euro ticket oder tank rabatt das ist
einfach viel zu kurzfristig gedanken
gedacht und nicht langfristig leider du
hast die maßnahmen die kurzfristigen
maßnahmen die jetzt gerade von der
politik erarbeitet worden sind
angesprochen denn es gibt aktuell ein
paar mehr hilfen vom staat tank rabatt 9
euro ticket werbens gehört damit
versucht also die bundesregierung
bürgerinnen und bürger finanziell zu
entlasten also ob das wirklich was
bringt und was ist sonst noch so gibt
das hat christian volk in einem beitrag
mal für uns zusammengefasst
als teil von entlastungspaket 1 fällt ab
morgen etwa die eeg-umlage weg wegen der
stark gestiegenen strompreise macht das
allerdings kaum etwas aus für haushalte
mit geringem einkommen gibt es außerdem
einen heizkostenzuschuss
270 euro für wohngeldempfänger im single
haushalt 230 euro für menschen die bafög
bekommen und ein sofort zuschlag für
familien mit wenig geld pro kind und
monat 20 euro
mit dem entlastungspaket 2 erhalten
erwerbstätige eine sogenannte energie
pauschale von 300 euro die müssen sie
allerdings noch versteuern rentner und
studierende gehen leer aus für familien
gibt es ein einmal bonus von 100 euro
für jedes kind und menschen die
sozialleistungen beziehen erhalten 200
euro
unterstützung vom staat gibt es auch im
bereich mobilität tank rabatt und neun
euro ticket sollen die geldbeutel bis
ende august schonen
der beitrag von christian volk und
franziska von tiesenhausen die frage an
euch beide was fehlt euch da wir haben
ein paar maßnahmen jetzt gehört und was
fällt euch
ich kann gerne mal versuchen
ich kann gerne mal versuchen anzufangen
und wird bei dem anschließen was ihm
missfallen gesagt hat nämlich dass wir
auch strukturelle maßnahmen brauchen die
generell entlasten und christoph hat
vorhin aufgemacht wie viele menschen in
deutschland eigentlich in armut leben
und der großteil der menschen lebt ja
nicht einfach nur in armut weil sie
arbeitslos sind sondern weil sie eine
geringe rente bekommen weil sie zu wenig
verdient haben indem verlauf ihres
lebens oder weil sie gerade arbeiten und
so wenig verdienen oder weil sie die
kinder von männchen sind die zu wenig
verdienen und ich finde eine
strukturelle maßnahme ist eben nicht
immer nur die eine oder die andere
pauschale sondern wir müssen einen
kommentar hat das ja vorhin gesagt wir
müssen über lohnerhöhungen reden auch
wenn wir armut bekämpfen wollen und auch
wenn wir nicht nur über die allerärmsten
reden sondern bis in die mitte der
gesellschaft
und da ist es jetzt so dass die
gewerkschaften sich dafür einsetzen dass
es sehr dolle tarifsteigerung gibt und
die sind wirklich notwendig und wirklich
auch alle mitzunehmen und da geht es
dann nicht darum steuer geld auszugeben
sondern da geht es dann wirklich darum
dass die löhne steigen werden ich glaube
das sind zum beispiel strukturelle mal
da muss man da nicht immer wieder 200
euro drauf werfen im monat vom staat
sondern da hat man eine langfristige
entlastung und andere fragen na ja wenn
die heizkosten immer weiter steigen wir
haben jetzt auch berichte von zb wurden
unternehmen devolo via die mieten auch
noch anziehen wollen wo man aber schon
weiß wie viel profite die eigentlich am
ende des tages mit dem wohnraum machen
vielleicht wird es zeit wieder über
fragen von nethen deckel und mietpreis
bremse zu reden und dafür zu sorgen dass
es dort eine strukturelle entlastung
gibt auch das dürfte zum beispiel
christian lindner entfallen belasteten
haushalt gar nicht und das ist das was
mir ganz so ein bisschen fehlt in der
debatte und olaf scholz hat ja diese
konzentrierte aktion vorgeschlagen und
hat dann gesagt ja der staat gibt ein
bisschen was dazu und wir machen ein
bisschen lohnzurückhaltung und genau das
finde ich falsch die miete ist das
würdest du dazu sagen sie ist das
genauso
ja ich sehe es auch genauso wie sarah
aber ich hätte noch noch paar andere
punkte wir haben auch in der korona
krise geschafft den steuersatz von 19
prozent auf 16 zu reduzieren aber es
geht und wissen sie wo die meisten
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmerinnen
leiten an sozialabgaben warum kann man
die sozialabgaben nicht reduzieren warum
können wir nicht anfangen zu sagen dass
geringfügige familien mehr kindergeld
bekommen ich meine ein besserverdiener
und spitzenverdiener interessiert 219
euro und ich glaube ihm tut es nicht weh
oder wenn ich höre dass wir drei 100
euro zuschuss bekommen aber rentner und
rentnerinnen und zu denken kein 310 euro
zuschuss bekommen haben sie keinen
gaskosten stromkosten oder wie reagiert
da die politik einfach auf so eine frage
würde mich gerne interessieren zusagten
warum ist er so willkürliche
entscheidungen seitens der politik und
warum kriegt man 300 euro als
arbeitnehmer oder arbeitnehmerin aber da
muss man auch darauf steuern bezahlen
das ist einfach wie gesagt nicht
durchdacht alles und das finde ich aber
sehr schade also wenn ich es weihnachten
wäre und ich mir zwei wünsche äußern
dürfte würde ich sagen mensch
deutschland wird endlich unbürokratisch
und handelns endlich redet nicht immer
und handelt auch langfristig und
effizienter als würde ich mir wirklich
wünschen
sarah dann hätte ich eine frage aus dem
stream an dichter zu denn ja du sagst es
richtig du kritisierst die ampel auch
aber trotzdem bist du ja sehr eng
verdrahtet eben in der politik und bis
politisch eben aktiv und nicola dyk
möchte gerne wissen warum das thema ich
bin armut betroffen in der politik immer
noch so ignoriert wird armutsbetroffene
arbeiten hart viele stunden pflegen ihre
angehörige sind krank oder behindert
also warum wird das thema in der politik
ignoriert
damals als es um rund und den
koalitionsvertrag ging haben wir uns
auch an seite der grünen partei aber
auch als grüne jugend und auch ich
persönlich mich sehr stark dafür stark
gemacht dass schon im koalitionsvertrag
wird zum beispiel anders über die frage
von hartz4 reden dass wir es schaffen
wirklich eine existenzsicherung zu
schaffen und klar könnte ich jetzt
einfach sagen ja die anderen politiker
die anderen parteien also die spd war
damals auch dagegen die hat jetzt ein
bisschen ihre meinung geändert dazu
zumindest ein kleines bisschen um die
fdp ist dagegen dass man da großartig
etwas ändert und finden das falsch und
ich könnte jetzt sagen ja sie haben es
einfach nicht genug verstanden
vielleicht muss man ihnen das noch mal
erklären aber das ding ist eben auch
dass gerade wenn wir zb über hartz4
reden dann hat das ganze natürlich
system und wenn wir über niedriglohnjobs
reden hat das auch system die niedrigen
löhne auf der einen seite sind die hohen
profite in großen unternehmen auf der
anderen seite niemand kann mir erzählen
dass sich grosse unternehmen wo wir in
den unternehmen seetagen dann millionäre
sitzen haben keine höheren löhne leisten
können aber damit mehr profite oben
entstehen macht es natürlich am ende des
tages sind womit ich nicht meine das
sind böse menschen die da oben sitzen so
funktioniert unser wirtschaftssystem
normal und hat vier hat es eben auch ein
abstecher an die leute denn ich nehme
natürlich lieber den schlecht bezahlten
job bevor ich dann in eine
grundsicherung rutsche die unter dem
existenzminimum ist das damals hartz4
und der niedriglohnsektor gleichzeitig
entstand das war dafür da um unternehmen
ist einfacher zu machen in deutschland
anzusiedeln um ein attraktiver
wirtschaftsstandort zu sein aber ich
finde das zeigt wieder dass nicht alles
was gut für das wirtschaftswachstum oder
für die wirtschaft ist immer automatisch
auch gut für die menschen ist und das
erleben wir jetzt gerade wieder und dann
würde ich sagen da müssen wir besser
darin werden uns durchzusetzen in diesen
fragen da braucht es ganz viele menschen
die den druck von aussen organisieren
gerade auch bei einer ampel die sich in
diesen fragen nicht einig ist du hast es
angesprochen wirtschaftswachstum wir
haben mit dem blick in die zukunft auch
nachgefragt beim deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung
wie es weitergehen soll mit der
steigenden inflation und wir hören auch
in diesen ton mal gemeinsam rein ein
gängiges missverständnis ist das wenn
die inflation wieder sinkt das problem
behoben ist
das ist nicht so die preise die jetzt
gestiegen sind für energie und für
lebensmittel die werden nicht wieder auf
das vorkrisen niveau sinken sondern vor
allem für energie werden auf jahre
hinaus hoch bleiben das heißt die
entlastungs paket der bundesregierung
sind gut sind willkommen aber sie können
ihnen nur temporär helfen nicht
permanent deshalb die einzige permanente
lösung um mit den höheren preisen
umzugehen sind höhere löhne höhere
sozialleistungen gerade für menschen die
wenig haben das ist der einzig wirklich
nachhaltige weg
mit ist der einzig wirklich nachhaltige
weg stimmst du dazu denn was du schon
natürlich auch häufig sagst ist es muss
auch ganz viel aus eigenem antrieb
kommen aus dem menschen selbst heraus
definitiv also ich bin auch der meinung
oder ich sehe auch die gefahr dass durch
diese geringfügige löhne auch natürlich
diese schwarzarbeit gefahr steigen
könnte dass viele menschen sagten danke
ich schwarz arbeiten und nebenbei geld
werden nun viele unternehmen
unternehmerinnen nutzen das auch aus was
ich mir wünschen würde dass wenn wir
haben ja so viele arbeitslose und ich
für immer wieder dass wir immer die
statistische zahlen seit dieser
jobcenter ja immer optimieren wollen
also komplette davon weg und versucht
die arbeitsuchende und arbeitgeber
irgendwie zusammen zu bringen wir haben
zum beispiel gestern als beispiele
bewerber kaffee ins leben gerufen mit
ukrainische frauen und mehrere
arbeitgeber es war wunderbar es hat so
super gemäht und geklappt also sowas
muss mehr fördern dass wir gucken da
gibt so viele arbeitssuchende und wir
ein fachkräftemangel schaut euch doch
mal die flughäfen dann schaut euch mal
die deutsche bahn hat also
fachkräftemangel arbeitsplätze haben wir
und die menschen die arbeits billig sind
haben wir auch hier die müssen wir nur
mehr motivieren und mehr auch mal die
möglichkeiten anbieten sich auch dort
auch zu präsentieren und auch mal zu
bewerben und die möglichkeit haben es
kommt viele frauen zu und sie können
sich noch niemand teilweise bewerbe ich
weiß es ist auch nicht die aufgabe von
jobcenter ist dass diese menschen eine
bewerbungs oder vorstellungsgespräche
training bekommen deshalb finde ich auch
gut weil ich ja jetzt seit drei monaten
ein verein habe dass man auch mehr
ehrenamtliches engagement auch
unterstützt und und seitens der politik
auch fördert das weil sie das sind
menschen die auch die sozial
benachteiligte frauen an die hand nehmen
können motivieren können helfen können
da sie nicht die behörden und die
verwaltung dann lasst uns noch mal
darüber reden vielleicht wie viel von
einem selbst kommen muss kommen kann je
nachdem wie man aufgewachsen ist denn in
unserer sendung soll es ja darum gehen
amts betroffenen selbst schuld ja oder
nein und zwar möchte ich auch gerne noch
ein kommentar von fabian kiene dazu von
youtube reinbringen er schreibt wie im
richtigen leben aufstieg erfordert
leistung wohlstand muss erarbeitet
werden um verteilung ist keine
staatsraison mietet vielleicht erst
deine meinung dazu und dann war sarah
deine antwort
es ist natürlich immer einen harten weg
das leben ist nicht zuckerschlecken also
ich kann aus meiner eigenen erfahrung
erzählen ich hatte auch einen sehr
harten weg hier in deutschland mich zu
integrieren die deutsche sprache zu
erlernen als unternehmerin das ist
natürlich schwer man hat es nicht
einfach aber ich bin der meinung dass
vorbilder und mentoren spiele wahnsinnig
große rolle und ich kenne viele hartz iv
empfängerinnen und empfänger sie haben
diese menschen gehabt nicht gehabt sie
haben kann vorbilder gab ihnen das
vorgelebt hat deshalb ist das wahnsinnig
wichtig dass wir diese menschen noch
mehr unterstützt auch emotional fangen
weil wie gesagt ich schon vorhin erwähnt
habe dafür sie nicht behörden und
verwaltungen zu stellen sondern wir
menschen sind dafür da um diese menschen
noch aufzufangen und es wäre
wünschenswert sagte ness wichtig dass es
auch mal den blick darüber gibt das dann
auch so was auch mehr auch unterstützung
gefördert weil ich kenne viele hartz iv
empfängerinnen die arbeiten wollen die
unabhängig sein möchte die
arbeitswilligen nur sie haben keine
möglichkeit sie haben sich vorgelebt
bekommen
sie haben nie gearbeitet und sie haben
auch angst und auch ihnen mut zu machen
dass du das schaffst das ist wahnsinnig
wichtig in der heutigen gesellschaft
es gibt ein paar kritischen stimmen dazu
mami bei youtube schreibt nirgendwo
arbeiten so viele leute für einen job
der nicht ausreicht davon zu leben wie
stellt sich frau pohl die arbeitswelt
eigentlich vor
was meinte er damit also wir haben ja
genug
arbeit auf dem arbeitsmarkt gibt es ja
genug arbeitsplätze sonst würden wir ja
nicht immer jammern wir würden jetzt
nicht recruiting agenturen in polen oder
in philippinen beauftragen wo wir
fachkräfte aus dem ausland holen
natürlich haben wir genug arbeitsplätze
und ich habe gestern zum beispiel auch
gelesen in der zeitung schwimmbäder die
wollen wir fördern des menschen noch ein
schwimmbäder als arbeiten er meint dass
der lohn nicht reicht er kritisiert
nicht dass es nicht genug arbeitsplätze
gibt erlass der lohn nicht reicht
ja und deshalb ist das ja auch diese
mindestlohn satz nicht richtig weil
viele hier auch sich darüber beklagen
ich kriege hartz 4 empfänger und warum
soll ich dann halt dafür arbeiten gehen
dafür reicht ja auch mein lohn das bin
ich aus empfänger belebe und brauche ich
kein mindestlohn deshalb müssen wir
diesen satz erhöhen definitiv und ich
bin immer noch der meinung wir müssen
mehr zuschuss und boni spiel wo denn
diese menschen ja auch arbeits billig
sind und davon gibt's jede menge sara
lee du bist selbst unter hartz iv
bedingungen groß geworden hat es bei dir
wirklich nur war es mit vorbildern getan
oder was hat es gebraucht für dich ich
meine du hast ja dann ein einser abitur
gemacht hast studiert hast ein
stipendium gehabt also waren es
vorbilder was war das bei dir
glück ich würde erstmal sagen dass es
ganz oft glück war ja ich hab zu den
richtigen zeitpunkten die richtigen
menschen kennengelernt ich hatte lehrer
die mich gefördert haben dem ich bis
heute dafür dankbar bin und menschen die
mich an die hand norman haben aber es
kann doch nicht von glück abhängen ob
man es schafft aus der armut heraus und
kinder in armut leben müssen oder nicht
und deswegen würde ich nochmal auf den
kommentar eingeben
es leistet gerade unglaublich viele
menschen unglaublich viel wir haben so
viel über systemrelevante berufe geredet
aber viele dieser systemrelevanten
berufe sind extrem schlecht entlohnt die
vielen rentner in die in deutschland in
armut leben die haben zum teil ihr
ganzes leben lang sehr sehr hart
gearbeitet und die rente reicht trotzdem
nicht zum leben weil sie nicht genug
renten punkte angesammelt haben weil sie
zu wenig verdient haben die ganzen
frauen in rente die in armut leben wir
haben unglaublich viel geleistet die
haben sich um ihre familie gekümmert die
haben kinder großgezogen die haben
angehörige gepflegt all das ist arbeit
aber das zählt dann nicht wenn man in
die rente geht die vielen
alleinerziehenden mütter in deutschland
die in armut leben sie leisten auch
unglaublich viel und deswegen geht es
mir darum dass menschen in der lage sind
davon dann zu leben gut zu leben
menschen möchten arbeiten und das ist ja
auch gut und auch richtig und
da aber daneben einen weg zu finden das
alle davon leben können dafür müssen wir
den niedriglohnsektor wirklich
austrocknen denn gerade können wir uns
alle anstrengen wir könnten alle die
ganze gesellschaft könnten einser abi
machen die ganze gesellschaft könnten
bachelor machen master und doktor dann
trifft diese komplett ausgebildet
generation aber auf den arbeitsmarkt wo
dann trotzdem jede fünfte person von dem
image richtung sektor arbeiten wird
davon werden menschen pfleger im sein
weil wir pflegen brauchen wir reden die
ganze zeit darüber die unter schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen arbeiten werden davon
werden menschen genau die kassiererin
die jetzt gerade so schlecht verdienen
also ich glaube das problem ist nicht
nur auf der seite wie viel die menschen
leisten sondern vor allem wie sie dafür
entlohnt werden und das möchte ich
ändern und dann geht es mir jetzt gar
nicht mehr also klar ist wahrscheinlich
kein geheimnis ich bin dafür dass gerade
sehr wohlhabende mehr dazu beitragen zur
gesellschaft ich bin für eine höhere
vermögenssteuer klar aber wenn es um
armut geht dann geht es auch um löhne
und zwar vor allem auch um die frage des
lohns und da finde ich gehe es jetzt
nicht unbedingt nur um umverteilung
sondern davon dass die menschen das
bekommen was sie verdienen und das ist
dann für mich leistung wirklich auch
anzuerkennen wir haben auch mit dem
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung auch noch mal
darüber gesprochen ob eben große
erfolgreiche konzerne mehr belastet
werden müssen den ton hören wir uns
zusammen an
wir sehen das gerade die großen
dax-konzerne rekordgewinne einfahren wie
mir nicht nur über die mineralölkonzerne
sondern auch über andere und wie in
jeder krise geht ist dass man die last
dieser krise auf alle schultern verteilt
und die starken schultern mehr tragen
müssen als schwache schultern
einer solchen situation muss man
vorsichtig sein jetzt nicht über
steuererhöhungen unternehmen zu
schwächen deshalb sehe ich schon den
staat in der pflicht hier mit
zusätzlichen entlastung paketen sowohl
die menschen als auch die unternehmen zu
unterstützen das bedeutet aber auch mehr
schulden auch da würde ich mir wünschen
dass die bundesregierung sich ehrlich
macht in einer solchen krise ist
erforderlich dass der staat geld in die
hand nimmt schlimmeres zu verhindern
marcel fritsche sagte also vorsichtig
sein jetzt nicht über steuererhöhungen
unternehmen zu schwächen daran die
siehst du diese gefahr nicht
also gerade haben wir eine situation in
der aus verschiedenen krisen auf der
einen seite der korona krise aber auch
die krise der steigenden preise wenige
unternehmen sehr gut rauskommen wir
reden gerade darüber ob spekulationen
stattfinden ob unternehmen sich gerade
über dem maße quasi an der krise
bereichern als das was sie normalerweise
an gewinn einfahren würden deswegen ja
jetzt auch dagegen vorgegangen werden
soll und deswegen finde ich fragen wie
die über gewinnt steuer sollten
diskutiert werden in der gesellschaft
das finde ich schon richtig weil am ende
der wohlstand den wir unserer
gesellschaft haben wird vor allem von
den arbeiter in unserer gesellschaft
erarbeitet und die die gucken gerade
ganz schön blöd wenn sie sich fragen wie
sie über ihre nächste heizkostenrechnung
hinweg kommen sollen man finde ich das
gerechtfertigt aber wo ich drauf
zustimmen würde ist dass daran
festzuhalten jetzt keine schulden zu
machen so einer situation also in so
einem kaputtsparen modus zu fallen wie
2008/2009 dass das nicht total negative
spirale los sag mir wird oft gesagt naja
sarah wir müssen jetzt auch wenn mit den
schulden weil wir machen das ja für eure
generation wir wollen eure generation ja
keinen kann hohen schulden hinterlassen
ja aber ich möchte auch dass man meiner
generation keine gespaltene gesellschaft
ungefährdete demokratie und marode
infrastruktur hinterlässt und deswegen
finde ich auch wichtig jetzt nicht so zu
tun man nennt das dann irgendwie
sondervermögen und dann versucht man
sich das irgendwie nett zu reden
ergänzungs haushalt wir haben viele
schulden gemacht dieses jahr und sie
waren auch zum teil gerechtfertigt und
da sehe ich auch handlungsbedarf bei der
regierung und wenn man sich daran jetzt
einfach nur festklammert weil man es mal
irgendwem am wahlkampfstand versprochen
hat dann finde ich das sehr unreife art
damit umzugehen
die miete ist wie stehst du dazu also
steuererhöhungen für erfolgreiche
unternehmen
ja weil ich ja selber ja auch als
unternehmerin als ex unternehmerin
bestätigen kann dass es mir auch nicht
so weh getan hat wenn ich an der
tankstelle vorbei gefahren bin und hans
bentzien erzählen oder 2010 höher war
das hat mir nicht wehgetan aber ich
finde es auch schade dass das auch viele
unternehmen nur corona gewinner sind
lebensmittelindustrie
ölindustrie dass man dann auf jeden fall
diese unternehmen dazu bringen sollte
mehr zu bezahlen und mehr steuern
abgaben zu haben müssen wenn ich schon
halte ich schon für sehr wichtig
wir haben auch noch kommentare und
vorschläge aus dem stream florian becker
schreibt es dürfen keine immobilien ist
dürfte keine immobilien giganten geben
jemand anderes flug vor große tech
unternehmen höher zu besteuern also das
sind ideen aus dem stream und ich möchte
auch noch mal auf noch weitere
persönliche geschichten auch aus dem
stream eingehen und auch auf kommentare
kurbi die messerschleifer also eure
namen sind fantastisch schrieb und mal
ehrlich die kleine spritze vom staat
damit damit kann ich knapp eine woche
einkaufen für alle hier also es gibt
einige menschen eben auch gerade mit
diesen sorgen bei uns im stream lob bei
youtube schreibt wie der klasse gemacht
auszahlungen der hilfe für hartz iv
empfänger auf den 23 07 verschoben und
das ist natürlich kann zusätzlich bei
den gestiegenen preisen für viele ein
riesenproblem also lasst uns vielleicht
auch noch mal auf all jene eingehen die
da wirklich jetzt enorm darunter zu
leiden haben wir haben es angesprochen
hartz-iv-empfängerin empfänger menschen
die grundsicherung bekommen wie soll das
quasi für die weitergehen beim wir haben
in unserem streaming auch darüber
gesprochen ja eigene antrieb um sich
auch aus einer lage zu befreien in der
man keinen job hat aber wie soll das
gehen daniela zum beispiel bei youtube
fragt sich genau das eigene antrieb zum
beispiel bei arbeitsunfähigkeit im
mieters hast du eine antwort für daniela
ja wenn man arbeitsunfähig ist jetzt
habt ihr nicht der meinung dass man
seitens der politik auch diese thema
umschulungen mehr auch fördern sollte
dass diese menschen auch chance haben
wie sich weiterzubilden er sich
umschulen und
solche menschen muss man noch mehr
unterstützen und helfen und auch thema
wo ich habe eine große problem sehe auch
wie spiegelung für mich ist das auch
österreich ist ein optimales land dass
sie es geschafft haben auch dieses thema
mitspielen spiegelung zu einfach
generieren warum schaffen wir sie in
deutschland ich spreche nicht von
monopolen wie hamburg berlin oder köln
sondern auch von kleinstädten oder auch
dörfer wie soll ich denn ein hartz4
empfänger oder jemand der wirklich auch
erkrankt ist wie sollte man diese miete
erhöhte miete einfach bezahlen darüber
macht sich glaube ich die politik
überhaupt gar keine gedanken
es gibt auch eine frage zum thema
chronisch krank das wurde ja eben auch
schon angesprochen und zwar von der
braker er würde gerne wissen was sie
beide ihr beide er schreibt die beiden
damen also was ihr beide zum thema
chronisch krank und hartz4 denkt es gibt
kaum bis keine hilfe für diese menschen
ich glaube das ist ja quasi etwas was
auch in der frage von arbeitsunfähigkeit
eine rolle spielt also mit was für einem
menschenbild geben wir eigentlich
einander um wie wollen wir in einer
gesellschaft von einander sorgen und da
ist für mich klar wenn menschen nicht in
der lage sind zu arbeiten dann sind sie
nicht in der lage zu arbeiten und das
heißt trotzdem nicht dass sie unter dem
existenzminimum leben sollten sondern
dass sie richtig abgesichert sein
sollten und deswegen finde ich der hartz
iv regelsatz muss steigen und dann
fragen mich immer leute nachher aber wie
soll ich das denn der lidl verkäuferin
lernen die verdient doch auch zu wenig
ja und sie sollte mehr verdienen und wir
sollten uns für beides einsetzen und
gerade menschen die chronisch krank sind
gerade menschen die arbeitsunfähig sind
brauchen diese unterstützung und das
gehört für mich dazu wenn wir sagen wir
sind eine gesellschaft die zusammenhält
gerade ist der hartz-iv-regelsatz
mindestens mindestens 200 euro unter dem
existenzminimum
angesichts der steigenden preise
wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr und wir
haben vor gar nicht allzu langer zeit
gezeigt dass wenn der politische wille
da ist man 100 milliarden euro
auftreiben kann und dann kann mir doch
keiner sagen dass wir dafür menschen
abzusichern wie zum beispiel chronisch
krank sind dass ihr daran jetzt sparen
müssen das finde ich falsch und deswegen
will ich total zustimmen dass es total
unter beleuchtet ist weil wir immer nur
darüber reden dass die menschen in hartz
iv doch faul sind und sich nicht
anstrengen und dabei hat die menschen
auch von oft und voll oft nicht
betrachtet werden die gar nicht mehr in
der lage sind zu arbeiten ja oft auch
deswegen nicht in der lage sind zu
arbeiten weil sie so hart gearbeitet
haben weil sie so schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen erlebt haben weil sie
über ihr körper hat es einfach nicht
mehr mitmacht und auch da müssen wir
darüber nachdenken wie wir eigentlich
menschen ermöglichen zum beispiel länger
ein job auszuführen und da jetzt einfach
nur leichtsinnig über ein höheres
rentenalter zu reden als werden menschen
in der lage zum beispiel harte arbeit in
der pflege einfach immer weiter und
immer weiterzumachen das ist für mich
unverständlich
ich schaue noch mal rein in eure
kommentare wir kommen nämlich auch
langsam zum ende und würde jetzt aber
gerne von euch auch noch mal was
aufgreifen wollen und zwar ist da noch
mal eine ganz persönliche frage im it is
an dich und zwar von simponi diaz wieso
ist frau pohl keine unternehmerin mehr
denn du hast ja beide perspektiven
ja weil ich meine erfolgsgeschichten
geschrieben habe und die pandemie zeit
hat mir persönlich gezeigt dass
besonders frauen unter dieser situation
leiden die frauen mussten teilweise
hausfrauen seien berufstätig seien auch
lehrerinnen seien und mutter und familie
leiten und die haben in alltagsdinge
sind sie gescheitert und das war immer
ein kindheitstraum von mir menschen oder
besonders frauen zu helfen sozial
benachteiligte frauen zu unterstützen
und deshalb habe ich mich im letzten
jahr aus meinem unternehmen
verabschiedet und habe in diesem jahr
ein verein gegründet um diese frauen zu
helfen und einfach auch ein stück meine
geschichte ihnen zurück zu geben ihnen
die möglichkeit zu bieten auch mal ihre
ziele zu erreichen ein selbstbestimmtes
leben zu führen weil diese frauen gibt
es nicht nur in afghanistan syrien iran
die gibt es doch leider hier in
deutschland und ich betreue mit meinem
verein frauen egal aus welcher herkunft
land egal welcher hautfarbe welche
religion wir haben auch viele deutsche
frauen die hartz iv empfängerinnen sie
die von gewalt betroffen sie die zu uns
kommen und das war auch der grund warum
ich mein unternehmen oft gegeben haben
weil irgendwann auch geld mich nicht
mehr erfüllt hat und auch mein
erfolgsgeschichten geschrieben habe und
jetzt möchte ich einfach in der heutigen
zeit besonders andere frauen helfen an
die hand nehmen sie zu begleiten liebe
mieter sei nicht da gehört so einmal
rein gehen darf wir haben ja auch schon
vorher waren es jetzt mittlerweile zwei
oder drei jahre ja schon einmal
miteinander diskutiert und ich wollte
dir einfach auch noch mal sagen auch das
was du gerade berichtet dass ich extrem
respekt vor dem hat was du machst und
dass du genau diesen frauen und menschen
hilft auch aus seiner geschichte heraus
ich bin auch ja auch weil ich in hartz4
aufgewachsen bin möchte ich mich jetzt
politisch für andere stark machen und
ich finde es total schön was du gerade
noch mal erzählt hast aus deiner arbeit
und wollte einfach auch mal danke sagen
dafür dass du das machst
danke liebe sarah das weiß ich zu
schätzen
juni die jungs kennen gelernt haben war
ich noch unternehmerin in jena und die
community sagt übrigens auch melfi bei
youtube danke frau heinrich hat
verstanden wo das problem liegt und ich
sage danke an euch beide an sara lee
heinrich und anime tispol dass ihr heute
unsere gäste watt und wir auch ein
bisschen mehr über euch sprechen und
eure meinung dazu kennen lernen konnten
und vielen dank an dieser stelle
danke
vielen dank natürlich auch an euch für
eure fragen und kommentare und ich
möchte zum ende von andreas kübler bei
youtube noch einen kommentar
herausgreifen denn er schreibt arbeit
muss sich wieder lohnen das geht doch
nicht dass menschen nur arbeiten um
arbeiten zu können und damit ist dieser
stream zu diesem thema für heute von uns
beendet und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal bis dahin tschüss